[Music]
thank you
what
your mother never told you you were
royalty the women in our family have the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now Ruby you're a princess aggress
the crowd
I think
I am having a panic at that
okay Ruby have it completely totally
ordinary day you got this
thank you
I feel like a freak ow I just want to be
Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
you are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
let's see what you're capable of
body armor
almost
it's time to go big
uh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh
anything for my algebra you do what no I
mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother
I think I like the first one better